make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Robin I'm
getting ready to go run some errands but
before I do I want to make a video
talking about the introduction of
Deadpool into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
now here's gonna be the funny thing
about this right here's the funny thing
about this everybody's looking for like
an in continuity way to explain because
of almost automatic universe sticks
largely to the continuity aspect right
like what would it look like if
superheroes existed outside your window
basically and a lot of people really
stick I don't want to see something like
that but with Deadpool he's completely
zany
and kind of out there and kind of a
little bit crazy and so in my mind
people are gonna be asking the question
if Deadpool's introduced into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as I care do this
basically always been there then what's
he been doing this entire time well I
can tell you what he's been doing this
entire time he has been playing raid
Shadow legends yes he has so what is
raid shadow Legends well raid is an epic
dark fantasy that's done right is a hero
collection turn-based game with over 400
champions for you to collect and
personally customized you can assemble a
team from 16 heroic factions there's a
Vincent tournaments taking place every
week you can discover 13 spectacular
locations enjoy a fully voiced Story
campaign which is amazing by the way the
best part of all this is the game is
absolutely free that's right it is free
to download and free to play some of the
best features and one of the things that
I enjoy the most is the multi battle
Auto mode in the sense that you can set
battles to run in Auto mode while you go
do something else you can spend less
time grinding and more time developing
your teams and fighting the fun stuff
there's always a way to compete and win
extra prizes every week the game is
growing super fast and check out this
cool road map that they published they
actually have huge plans for updates in
the game for over six months so there's
an infinite amount
content for you to enjoy and there's no
time to get bored so what are you
waiting for go to the link in the video
description click on the special link
that will get you 50,000 silver and a
free epic champion as part of the new
player program to start your journey but
to the topic at hand
the idea of Deadpool and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe here's a thing I
wouldn't do that whole thing of trying
to make sure it fits in continuity I
wouldn't worry about all that right
because I think it makes it complicated
see here's a funny thing about Deadpool
here's the thing about Deadpool that
made him so cool when it went make him
so cool when I came to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and really just like
the Fox movies right the idea of
Deadpool is that he was basically a a
parody on superheroes it's really what
he was he didn't start out that way
right like late list let's go to the
comics for sec it was gonna be an
important thing because honestly I would
put him in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
the same way Christopher priest did so
let's go to the comics right let's wind
the clock back to like 1997 right and
here's the reason why that matters it's
because before 1997 Deadpool was
introduced by Rob Liefeld a New Mutants
issue number 98 and at the time Marvel
was basically getting ready to get rid
of New Mutants and to launch a whole new
story called x-force which was
ridiculously popular when it first came
out it was an amazing story and so the
idea here was that when Deadpool was
introduced he was kind of like your
standard fare of like these darker
mysterious anti-heroes right and it made
sense because Wolverine had kind of set
that popularity in motion right some guy
who shows up
who's got kind of like a dark checkered
past you don't really know a whole lot
about it
you just know why there's mystery and
intrigue there and he's also kind of
cool this sense that he seems to have
somewhat of a soft spot it's just a
matter of sort of figuring that out
right like women love that stuff and so
because of that like Deadpool was
introduced in the same fashion and
Deadpool resonated with fans right
people really loved him the problem was
by the time we got to the mid 1990s we
had the comic Buster I you know we
talked about they come and bust a whole
bunch of tons Marvel made the right move
at the time by throwing Deadpool into
different stories having a crossover
with Wolverine a couple times throwing
him in some of some other stories and
robbing other heroes that didn't that
weren't really confined to stories about
cable right you know the leader of
x-force but all this changed in 1997 and
the reason why was because Deadpool was
viewed as one of those characters where
maybe he was bankable maybe he wasn't
like his circle chase miniseries by Mark
Waid sold pretty well so like there was
obviously a market for his character but
interest in like the dark edgy gritty
characters right so I GW bridge and
cable and x-force
that it was all basically dropping off
and so people were kind of like alright
well I mean at least Marvin was like
let's you know whatever like we're not
gonna cancel him but like we're not
gonna give him top billing right like
what are the throne somewhere in between
just kind of see how it plays out
because there's enough people buying it
to keep him keep him afloat but not
enough that he should be getting like
the same kind of riders is like Spider
Man or something like that
and so as a result of that they handed
over to Christopher I'm sorry not not
Chris for Kelly to Joe Kelly and an Ed
McGuinness and McGuinness through the
comics like the first four or five
issues I think or something like that
then he dropped off and Joe Kelly wrote
for the first somewhere between 15 to 25
issues I think and then he left but Joe
Kelly's his run on Deadpool is kind of
considered to be the first instance of
Deadpool getting like this dark humor
right and so as a result of that uh
there were only a couple instances under
Joe Kelly's run when Deadpool broke the
fourth wall what he was doing was stuff
like making fun of the story right like
this is a ridiculous story is it just
different things like that
not all the time it wasn't something
that was constantly in your face that
version of Deadpool the one that you
know now that would come later instead
what you got was was little me a little
sir uh scenarios were like Kitty Pryde
who was hanging out with Wolverine at
the time was annoying Deadpool so we
uppercutted her out of the panel right
just little things like that that were
hilarious it was amazing but but that
was that was kind of the the most you
got but end up wouldn't up happening is
Joe Kelly left right Joe Kelly ended up
leaving Deadpool and the result was that
he was handed over to a handful of
characters Sierra I guess a handful of
writers Gail Simone was one of those
writers a lot of you guys probably know
her from her run on Batwoman different
things like that but the real big change
to Deadpool came when he was given a
Christopher priest and the reason why
was because Christopher priest at the
time was a writer where comic book
characters would go to die that's
basically what it was right if mama
wanted to write a character out if they
wanted to cancel their series they would
handed a Christopher priest he would
finish the story and and it would be
that way and it had been that way really
since the run of Power Man and Iron Fist
that's when Christopher freeze basically
became the guy that canceled stories and
the reason why was because at the time
kind of winding back a little bit
further here let me let me sidetrack for
a second at the time Power Man and Iron
Fist was resoundingly popular under Mary
Jo Duffy the issue was that it wasn't
what what editor-in-chief Jim shooter
wanted to do he wanted like darker
edgier stories she was telling cut like
like comedy stories like funny stories
and people loved Power Man and Iron Fist
but because of the fact that it didn't
work out
they ended up filing her they took her
off the title they replaced with curb
music Kurt Busiek did the same thing she
did and then they got rid of her Buick
and then they handed over to Christopher
priest
Christopher priests basically ended the
series by having an fist punch through a
wall by fin and it killed him fans were
pissed they were so mad and so as a
result of that Christopher priest became
the guy who would basically cancel
stories for Marvel and so when he took
over the title the first story that he
did and in terms like the first issue
that he had here Deadpool is basically
walking through this trailer park and
he's being escorted there by some guy in
a suit or something along those lines
and so Deadpool's going through this
trailer park and and he is met um with
this this place is supposed to be his
right it's like well here's your trailer
you know here's where you're gonna be
staying and when they open the door it's
all the characters that Christopher
priest had cancelled and Deadpool takes
one look around and leaves he's like no
way I'm staying in this place it's like
this nope he's like not happening I'm
not getting cancelled so like he goes
walking he jumps up to this giant lake
and wakes up in this this kind of you
know liquid stasis pod and that's where
his story starts and then from there
Christopher priests made the Deadpool
that you know today right the one who
would break the fourth wall by
addressing the reader on the that kind
of a page oh really she Hawk was the
first one to do that under um John Byrne
but but in terms of like break-in
they're breaking the fourth wall within
the pages of the story that's where
Deadpool really blew up right like
addressing the reader talking to you
directly telling you how dumb he thought
the story was and all that kind of stuff
people loved it they did they ended up
like gangbusters the guy who was
supposed to cancel Deadpool ended up
saving him and that's one of the things
that people sort of tend to forget but
that's what I would do right like I
wouldn't worry about trying to fit
Deadpool into continuity I would just
throw him why drop him into the story
just kind of happened like just up here
they're just like man dude this universe
is a lot more put together than the one
that I was in before like Fox sucks and
we're something on those lines making
fun of Fox you know being the character
that continually breaks the fourth wall
that basically says hey look audience I
get you guys are here to watch kind of
book movie and I know you guys want to
suspend your disbelief but come on a
movie with a giant green guy that rages
and smashes stuff and then you guys like
didn't like the version who became super
smart like why did they waste him like
that like let him be the guy that's our
voice in the Emma comma but right
40 of the things that don't make sense
to us so on and so forth not all the
time right the guy doesn't need to be a
critic but he doesn't need to be like a
critic of the MCU that's not really what
he needs to be but certainly throw him
in in a way where it allows us as the
viewer to have fun with it right you
just kind of have fun and have a good
time I just sort of let these go and
just sort of see where they were see
where the chips fall because that's how
Deadpool is that's how that's how it
wasn't Deadpool 1 that's how he wasn't
Deadpool 2 I mean for God's sake you had
the Invisible Man who was invisible all
the way up to the point he died and then
you learned it was Brad Pitt so I was
just you know little things like that
that are that are super cool let that
version of Deadpool stay you know give
us that guy he doesn't have to fit into
continuity he doesn't have to fit into a
nice little organized box he just needs
to be the guy that lets us have fun and
following the Christopher priest
treatment when it with his first issue
where Deadpool like makes fun of the
fact that he's just kind of like okay no
way I'm gonna sit here and be canceled
or anything like that take that and kind
of adapt it to to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and then just kind of go
forward accordingly right I think it
would be a resounding success I think it
would be hilarious but let me know what
you guys think down in the comments
section well that being said we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here - comments explained make sure
you guys are the sub button to become
part of the rod core if you guys enjoy
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]